welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of rick and
morty season five episode for
rick dependence spray a title playing on
independence day
but here it's welcome to birth of a
giant incest baby yeah this episode was
pretty gross but had plenty of fun
visual jokes hidden in the animation
that are worthy of breaking down
and a reminder that one way you can
support this channel is by checking out
one of our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com including our loki
out of time shirt or another new latest
obsession shirt the black widow the red
deep design very cool
and again check that all out at
newrockstarsmerch.com okay we begin at
st
equals hospital which showed up in the
pilot episode it's shaped like a barn
equus of course meaning horse related
and here in the parking lot the cars
have stickers with a horseshoe shape
save the horses no glue for you morty
realizes what this breeding mount could
do for him
that's a breeding mount the nurses use
it to collect reproductive material yeah
the animators made morty's eyes grow
insanely wide
and beth comes back in and says okay
let's go see this latest piece of marvel
[ __ ] you kids are [ __ ] over yeah
of course beth has got to use that word
but it's also another example of rick
and morty making fun of the mcu with so
many marvel screenwriters coming from
the rick and morty writers room
including loki writers mike waldron and
tom kaufman quantum mania writer jeff
loveness and she-hulk writer jessica gao
who wrote pickle rick rick similarly
mocked the mcu in the vat of asset
episode last season
if ant-man and the wasp can do it i'm
not interested and he brings up robert
downey jr's wild past later this episode
look at iron man that actor was an
animal in the 90s literally waking up in
bushes
his agent had to catch him with a
butterfly net so after one week with
that breeding mount morty sips samoj
right from the carton just like he did
after spending some
quality time with the gazorpzork bot in
season one so rick is building a bio
weapon to fight
you know that race of underground
dwelling cannibal horse people that
we're always fighting yeah the chuds
yeah shud or cannibalistic humanoid
underground dwellers was a campy 1984
horror film about monsters that live in
tunnels beneath new york city but here
the h is apparently swapped out for
horse people but they don't appear to be
true cannibals if they eat
humans not other horse people cannibals
might just be a stereotype that the
warring humans have for them now we
never learn exactly what technology rick
is using to activate this
stuff but only that he calls it
otherworldly forces
and an inhuman amount of power just
reminded that rick's tech
often extends to the occult as we saw in
season one something wicked this way
comes into the promo for next week's
episode that's gonna deal with some of
that stuff in his adventure with jerry
but the machine explodes leaving morty
with his ears ringing in the aftermath
and the sperm monsters are now attacking
neighbors in this foggy atmosphere it
seems like a visual homage to the mist
frank derabon's super violent 2007
stephen king adaptation about
interdimensional beasts eating people
alive
and when rick blasts these things the
laser leaves both an entrance and an
exit wound if they're going to animate
the deaths of giant sperm monsters i'm
just thankful that the ballistics logic
is consistent rick steers past the
bodies of their neighbors can you give
me a minute i'm trying to steer around
the bodies of our neighbors
oh that felt like gene yeah gene was
their nosey neighbor whom morty snapped
at in the season three whirly early
conspiracy episode
everything okay here mind your own
goddamn business gene
summer wonders holy [ __ ] how big are
space sticks
don't answer that damn they must be huge
which the president later echoes
it's how big a space sticks same page
club notice as the monster rams them off
the road
in the car morty's eyes stay closed for
all of it like he's cringing to see a
part of him and his
stuff about to kill him and his family
but secret service saves them
coding them all in that monster's fluid
keith david returns as the president and
we visited this war room back in season
two's get schwifty episode also this
bunker tunnel in season three's finale
and in the wide shot you can see maps
showing the death valley region of
southern california which is not far
from vegas and the grand canyon and that
filter water pitcher is right behind
jerry ready to pour
rick tries to justify the monsters well
mr president the theory of cosmic dna
has been around for decades chupacabras
yeti stonehenge ancient rome are these
all myths
monsters legends or different names for
sperm from outer space yeah ancient rome
isn't a myth and this whole thing of all
the worldwide folklore you've heard is
actually this
it's just becoming a huge annoying trope
that shows up in like every sci-fi and
horror thing now
bird box hbo is the outsider mortal
kombat the old guard
hereditary x-men apocalypse but rick is
half-assing it here hoping that the
president will just buy it considering
before he was able to fool him with a
snake
up the pant leg trick but an expert
arrives hello hello sorry i'm late
this is professor shaboob with the
world's leading expert on sperm yeah dr
shabubu
works at the spi according to his badge
which i'm wondering might be the sperm
production institute
and his clothes are covered in gross
stains considering the president is
involved with all this he seems to be
based on that eccentric area 51
scientist in independence day dr oaken
shabu is voiced by nick rutherford who
wrote this episode and was part of the
comedy group good neighbor alongside
snl actors back bennett and kyle mooney
kyle mooney actually came using this
episode as the voice of blazin
oh no i can't reach that idiot
shabooboo has captured a monster
obviously our first steps will be to
analyze its dna and figure out what
these
beautiful proteins oh yeah as he got cut
off shabooboos calling them beautiful
creatures
jerry pours water for the president
thrilled to do so reminding us of
jerry's globe
and induced wildest fantasy last season
where he made sure people stayed
hydrated with mountain sweat water
deliveries now the president won't send
women on the team
and women it's a fine suggestion but i
doubt their leader will be a sexy queen
that needs to be kickboxed
100 male marines but of course this is
exactly the case summer was right again
[Music]
you can't beat me you didn't bring a
woman that could kick box
the marines talk big i'm gonna make
these things pregnant with death no fear
no humility
zero chance of consequences yeah that
hand clap asp is a nod to the bro
hand clasp that the macho marines do
before their deadly suicide mission and
aliens
the hall gets blown open rick has
mechanical arms that automatically
extend to keep him and morty from being
sucked out and the attack came from some
sperm artillery
the sperm made a catapult are they
getting smarter no you're getting dumber
because that's a trebuchet nobody knows
the difference
they're reloading that textbook
trebuchet yeah classic rick um
actually there trebuchets use
counterweights and slings to fling the
projectile making it go even further
whereas catapults just kind of simply
hurl it with a liver but before i
continue thanks to blue blocks for
sponsoring this video
see a long day of staring at screens can
be really tough on your eyes
on particularly screen intense days i
noticed my eyes started to feel heavy am
i starting to have problems sleeping
blue light damages our eyes and leads to
digital eye strain
symptoms of digital eye strain include
blurred vision headaches and dry watery
eyes
for some folks this could even affect
your energy level well
blue blocks was created to fix this
problem and block out blue light with
high quality lenses
blue blocks are evidence-backed and made
under optics laboratory conditions in
australia they have over 40 styles of
frames and come in prescription
non-prescription and readers so they
have frames for every need go to
blueblocks.com
new rockstars or click the link below
and you will get 20
off your order and get free shipping
worldwide on orders over 115 dollars so
get your energy back
sleep better and block out the unhealthy
effects of blue light with blue blocks
that's b
l u b l o x dot com slash new rockstars
or just click the link below
code automatically applied at checkout
for 20 off also from now until june 30th
blue blocks is having a special end of
the financial year sale
where you can get 25 off any orders over
160 dollars and save
30 off any order over 315 dollars
and thanks again to blue lox for
sponsoring this video the plane crashes
and yeah it is totally insane for blazon
to have survived without a scratch
because notice how after morty
only rick and the other marines seem to
parachute out morty helps free this
two-tailed sperm that he named sticky
similar kind of to the relationship
between hiccup and toothless and how to
train your dragon
sticky's perspective shows a magenta
tinted world with a glowing aura
showing his origin point but the magenta
color kind of matches the color of his
future egg destination
blazing goes down pretty fast revealing
that he wears a thong
morty find my wife tell her i wasn't
wearing her thong that's a photocopy of
sports illustrated swimsuit model kathy
ireland it's it's my wife
we have sex yeah the cover he actually
shows here in his photocopy is the 1989
25th anniversary swimsuit issue cover
just with a different pose from kathy
ireland there and then after the queen
captures them
morty apologizes yeah not exactly
accepting apologies while i'm stuck here
as [ __ ] solo yeah obviously just like
han frozen and carbonite i love it rick
uses morty's pants to
choke the queen and i know this
episode's nasty enough but morty's pants
were
probably the burial ground for most of
her siblings in vegas the billboard
credits professor shaboobu not summer
for giving the egg
is now enlarged on top of the pyramid of
the luxor casino so
now the threat is that they will make a
giant
incest baby what who told you that what
i was finishing his sentence oh right
so this could be where this already
gross episode lost a lot of you
but it is something that's been brought
up on the show before back in season
three's tales from the citadel
i wish incest porn had a more mainstream
appeal
for a friend of mine i think the writers
just might find it darkly funny that
incest has been weirdly normalized by
shows like game of thrones and is now
a surprisingly popular porn sub category
i mean not to kink shame but
it is still illegal and biologically
unethical to actually carry that out so
maybe
find something else to vent yourself
rick shames morty
can't change my nature what are you a
scorpion and a navajo fable everyone can
change their nature morty that's what
defines our species
yeah rick is referring to the fable of
the scorpion and the frog also known as
the scorpion of the tortoise in other
versions where a scorpion cannot help
but stab the animal giving him a ride
across the river because it is his
nature but it's also interesting to hear
rick tell morty to change his nature
since change
often seems antithetical to this show's
episodic reset structure when in reality
the characters are evolving just in
little subtle ways the chud kingdom is
marked with equine imagery
horse heads and statues horse shoes on
the door hinges
on the throne pedestal on candelabras
and their belt buckles and i love how
when they're emotional when they talk
they pronounce their consonants with
horse
winnies morty says this is out there
even for us
they can hear you morty yeah a meta joke
from the writers acknowledging that this
episode might have been a bit out of
line but they managed to slip it past
adult swim in the network sensors though
i would say the show seems to have a
cart blush to make any jokes at once and
as they prepare to cook them the chuds
have this stupid chant that
accounts for them eating the bones by
the accident is named ponetta which
sounds like a play on pony except in
spanish and portuguese filipino some
other languages
punyta and variations are slang for
masturbation or masturbator meanwhile
the military arms the vegas wall with
spermicide and
all vegas regulars including zoomanity
in the magician the amazing jonathan
who's a real guy and as they storm the
gates
the big one is armed with explosives
similar to the big orc with the
explosive torch and lord of the rings
the two towers
so beth and summer have to take charge
ready for all of the responsibility with
none of the credit
let's nancy reagan this [ __ ] so in case
there's any confusion over summer's joke
here in the final years of ronald
reagan's presidency
reports suggested his mental sharpness
began to decline
and really his advisors and his wife
nancy reagan had to be more hands-on
and they never really got the credit for
keeping the country running day-to-day
so they steered the sperm into a casino
with this sign reading
russian roulette and loose slots
you know at the mirage the show is the
sultana swoon the man the myth the
musical
and they use its volcano fountain to
burn more of the sperm and with the
combined forces of the chuds and the
vegas performers are able to kill the
rest
sticky kills the queen but impregnates
the egg anyway leading summer to try to
abort it but the president stops her
that's a human life and this is an
election cycle and then blazen's actual
wife kathy ireland voiced by christina
ricci starts to teach morty a lesson
about not lying even when you're ashamed
of your gross kinks but there's no
actual takeaway here because rick's chud
baby is born and immediately burrows
into the earth so rick hits the staples
that was easy
button leading to this post-graded scene
where an astronaut repairs a space
station like in the movie gravity he's
missing his kids
like sandra bullock's character did and
then the giant incest baby appears said
to the music of 2001 space odyssey
recalling the star child that bowman
reincarnates into at the end of that
kubrick film
yeah we get it but did we need this
whatever i guess i still laugh
hey if it helps you remember a lot of
rick and morty episodes could be set in
alternate realities not the main series
continuity though i guess that was not
the case last episode with those graves
visible in the background and when
recurring characters like the president
return it does make it somewhat more
likely it could be in the main universe
continuity though again it's not like
those episodes were directly referenced
by the president
whatever i still loved a lot of the
jokes in this episode in the animation
details so whatever i'm happy let me
know what you thought of this episode
and you can support new rockstars again
by checking out our merch options
including our latest
obsessions at new rockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching see you next week
bye
[Music]
you